you know I try not to repeat myself on
this show but I don't try very hard
which is why I end up repeating myself
all the time so the subject of so-called
dinks childless by choice couples who
have a dual income and no kids hence the
acronym is one that I have Revisited on
multiple occasions and in fact you might
think that I have said every last thing
one could possibly say on the subject
which is undoubtedly the case uh I've
made my point about the dinks and that
there is you know there's not much else
that needs to be added but then over the
weekend uh CNBC decided to release a
mini documentary about the dink it's
titled why more Americans are going
childree it already has over half a
million views on YouTube and I watched
the video and the video focuses mainly
on one young married couple from
Massachusetts who self-identify as dinks
dink dink dink dink dink now just as a
fun exercise I want you to imagine what
a millennial dink couple from
Massachusetts might look
like what does the dink wife look like
most importantly what does the dink
husband look like like draw a picture in
your mind and now we'll watch the video
and you will see that the image in your
mind is exactly correct you have used
your psychic powers to see this couple
before you actually saw them we got
married fairly young and we both just
decided for many reasons we didn't want
kids and then at some point we heard the
acronym Dink and I think just really
fell in love with it okay first of all I
mean that's exactly what you pictured
isn't it you might have been slightly
off on the wife that was a little
ambiguous but uh the husband I mean you
had figured out the long hair the nose
piercing all of it just screams dink
dinkle B I mean it screams the kind of
man who would confess to falling in love
with the name dink dick I like it how is
that possible how is it that you heard
Dink and she like wow I love that that
is great that's what I am it
resonates it's a name it sounds like a
name that was invented by someone like
me to make fun of you Mr dink is really
upset but instead they came up with it
themselves apparently because they're a
bunch of damned dinks there are more
Americans that are deciding not to have
children and it's purposeful this new
trend has led to the rise of a new type
of household more commonly referred to
as dick dick dual income no kids oh yeah
dual income no kids that's perfect for
us that's absolutely right children are
the death of net worth pretty crude uh
but honestly very true this household
configuration of dual income Partners
living alone without children is on the
rise in 2022 was around 43% of
households and that's about a 7%
increase from a decade previously in
2022 43% of American surveyed said
they'd want to get married but just a
little more than a quarter said they
were sure about wanting children the
term dink is becoming more PR prominent
now because of financial challenges and
they see children as just another
Financial challenge what's so damn funny
of course they have a dog too you know
even looks it looks like a it looks like
a dog that it looks like a dink dog
looks like a dog a dink would have just
you everything about it their house
everything they say children are just
another Financial Challenge and that's
all they are the word just is is quite
telling because there's apparently
nothing else to say about new human life
other than the fact that it's an
economic burden a child is a bill and
nothing more yes I'm only a bill the
idea that there there may be more to
life that some things transcend material
concerns that not everything has a price
tag that there is more to life than the
bottom line none of that is take into
consideration at all according to a 2023
survey of dinks Finance played a major
role in their decision to not have
children more than a quarter of
respondents said they simply aren't able
to financially support a child at the
moment when we advise clients about
having children we honestly don't even
give them the full real details and the
real numbers it's one of those things if
you actually see the math of it all it
might make you decide to not have
children it costs a family an estimated
$310,500 to age 18 adjust it for higher
future inflation and that doesn't even
include the cost of college okay now
this really isn't uh the point I want
focus on but but it should be noted that
everything you've just heard is nonsense
33% of of the dinks say they can't
afford a child now I believe that 33%
said that in a survey but what they're
saying is ridiculous I mean there are
families with significantly less
financial means who are managing to
raise multiple children and can still
live perfectly comfortably and care for
their children and themselves without
the risk of starvation you know as a
general rule if you have decided that
something is financially impossible for
you but but then you look around and you
see that literally billions of people
throughout the history of the world have
done this impossible thing with less
financial means than you have at your
disposal that's a good indication that
the problem isn't really your finances
if you're struggling with collections
medical bills credit cards or personal
loans you need to check out PDS debt PDS
debt is an Innovative One-Stop shop to
guide you on your journey to freedom
from debt there's uh no one-size
fits-all solution to becoming debt free
which is why PDS debt offers multiple
programs and solutions tailored to your
specific needs budgets and future
financial goals whether you're going to
go through a serious hardship or just
can't seem to keep up with the high
interest on your credit cards PDS debt
will craft a custom solution to give you
instant relief and start saving you
money if you're making payments every
month on your debt and your balances
aren't going down this program is for
you BDS debt provides options that
consolidate your debt into one low
monthly payment anybody with $10,000 or
more an eligible debt qualifies as and
there is no minimum credit score
required they want to help anyone with
good and bad credit doesn't matter plus
with PDS debt you'll save thousands and
interest uh and fees and pay off your
debt in a fraction of the time PDS debt
is offering my listeners a free debt
analysis and it only takes 30 seconds
head over to PDS debt.com Walsh to get
your free debt assessment today that's
PDS debt.com Walsh today
also okay I mean you hear these figures
all the time it cost it cost $7 million
to raise a child for one day like it no
it doesn't it does not cost $310,000 to
raise a child to the age of 18 it
doesn't that's almost 20 grand a year
okay by that logic I should be spending
$120,000 a year just on my kids I assure
you I am not in fact when we had our
twins I was making $44,000 a year this
was 10 years ago now granted this was 10
years ago okay this it's been inflation
but that would still mean that that
nearly all of my income was going to my
kids I mean we would have been homeless
and starving but we weren't I mean it is
more than possible to raise a child on
significantly less than 20 grand a year
it just might mean that you're driving a
less fancy car and you're buying a less
fancy TV and you're going on less fancy
vacations and you're learning how to
actually make meals from scratch at home
instead of ordering door Dash five
nights a week I mean you spent
$967 on road service there are ways to
raise children without spending over a
quarter of a million dollars to do it I
know there are ways because again
literally billions of humans since the
dawn of the species have figured out how
to do it we're the only ones it's like
five minutes ago we all looked around as
a as a species and said this is too
expensive we can't do this anymore what
been doing it the whole time what do you
mean it's too expensive seeing our
friends really struggle with that
balancing act
because appreciate the the flexibility
that we have financially because we
don't have children yes that dude is
reading a book titled hot and unbothered
okay now I looked it up and apparently
the full title is hot and unbothered how
to think about talk about and have the
sex you really want so so yes behind the
scenes here okay the CNBC crew came to
this dink's house they wanted to get
some b-roll of this couple sitting on
the couch and pretending to read
together which is something they've
they've probably never done even once in
real life okay they've never sat on the
couch and read together they're just on
their phones all the time not even
looking at each other uh but they wanted
to get this and so and so this guy
decided to pull hot and unbothered from
the shelf for the scene that's the kind
of book that if you have it you take it
down from your shelf and you hide it
under the couch when the film crew comes
it's not a book that you deliberately
showcase but then again these are
obviously not people who have much of a
Capac capity for shame because they're
dinks we'll watch one more clip and I
think that will be enough here it is
besides saving on Child Care dinks can
also fully reap the benefits of
combining their finances to look at both
of our incomes coming in and see how
we're able to handle all of that because
we don't have extra finances with a
child it's much more comfortable we get
to focus more on the things that we want
to do and and saving a lot of that money
for the future and worry less about the
the day-to-day finances of the house and
our bills money isn't the only expense
that dinks can save on the free time is
actually one of the biggest things for
me so we built me a little
office/bedroom out here we definitely
have some more expensive Hobbies I uh
build mechanical keyboards like uh
computer keyboards in my spare time and
just parts and stuff for that can be
very expensive not having children has
given us the freedom to pursue other
things remodeling our home um I'm a
beekeeper I'm really handy and I like
doing stuff around the
house I wouldn't have the time to just
do that after work if I feel like it if
I had you know a child to care for I got
all this extra time and money they can't
even update their kitchen but uh let
let's review a few things here first of
all uh I have more than 6 months saved
and I have six kids we've also remodeled
multiple homes I've even kept bees how
hard can it be
okay all with kids so they have not
listed one single thing that people with
kids can't do they haven't listed one
single thing that I myself haven't
already done or I'm not currently doing
besides building keyboards in my spare
time I haven't done that I also don't
have a separate bedroom from my wife as
this guy apparently does I mean because
he's absolutely determined to fulfill
every single last demeaning stereotype
of a male Millennial dink that he can
think of so when you hear this this um
anti-natalist propaganda telling you
about all the things you can't do when
you have kids It's always important to
remember that it's a lie I mean again
there is nothing that these people can
do that I can't or that you can't if you
have kids now in some cases it may take
more effort it may take more planning it
may take more
sacrifice um but it can be done you can
save money you can plan for the future
you can have free time you can be
financially secure you can even build
keyboards if you want for some reason
you can do that too now you may suffer
misfortunes or or or setbacks that may
make those things more difficult but
that can happen and will happen in one
form or another whether you have kids or
not but all that is beside the point you
know arguing the case on financial terms
is playing right into the dink hands
which is never good because you never
know where their hands have been oh
dinkleberg aren't you going to come over
and give my wife a congratulatory hand
touch even if Financial Security and
prosperity is perfectly possible and
attainable for families with children
and it is it is still true that your
life will be easier financially if you
don't have kids I mean that is true I
don't deny that kids don't cost or don't
need to cost $310,000 to raise but they
do cost something I mean it ain't cheap
so yes in the end it's true that the
dinks will avoid certain financial
difficulties for now anyway and why is
the carpet all wet Todd I don't know
Margo until they're old and the money
runs out and they up alone in a nursing
home because they don't have any kids to
care for them or support them but for
now it will be easier
sure and that is the only selling point
you'll notice that every time we get
this kind of advertisement for the dink
Lifestyle the only thing they ever want
to talk about is the finances the
supposed benefits of being a dink all
fall into one
bucket that's it and even in that bucket
the benefits are greatly exaggerated but
the point is that they don't have
anything to say outside of the
money they never even bother claiming
that being a dink will give you a more
purposeful life or a more exciting and
interesting life they never say that
it'll bring more meaning into your life
or more love into your life they don't
even try to claim that the dinks have
greater opportunities for Joy or
fulfillment they certainly don't mention
anything about Legacy you know Joy
meaning love Legacy purpose these aren't
even part of the sales pitch
which which really tells you what you
need to
know yes some aspects of life will be
easier for a while if you don't have
kids but like why are you living a life
in the first place what is the point of
it what should you be doing with your
life what What Gives Life Meaning you
pass butter oh my God these are
questions that the dinks in that video
don't seem to have asked
themselves they're too busy reading
self-help sex books in their separate
bedrooms gloating over how easy their
lives are while never stopping consider
what life is or what they are meant to
do with it or what will make it
meaningful and that is why they are
today once again caning I'm
[Music]
alone